when our officials in zapparista say
that at least 23 civilians have been
killed and dozens injured in a Russian
strike on a civilian Convoy well let's
go now live to our special correspondent
Alex Crawford who's in safaricia Alex uh
what are the circumstances here
well I think the actual detail has got
filmed certainly certainly the Ukrainian
authorities are blaming this on the
Russians and saying that there were
three rocket attacks just in this area
it was an area that was particularly of
vulnerable for civilians because there
was a long line of Civilian Vehicles you
can see some of them behind me there
were at least eight different Vehicles
now this this via these Convoy were
taking in humanitarian Aid to the
Russian controlled territories part of
the area which Vladimir Putin the
Russian president is trying to Annex
from Ukraine you could see a big crater
which is where one of the Rockets hit
and this had a devastating impact on the
line of Civilian Vehicles many of the
Dead are still inside the vehicles we've
been asked to step back a bit from the
area because those people are
investigators who are already Gathering
evidence for what they view as a
potential War crime we counted at least
a dozen bodies
some of them are already in body bags
but many of them are still sitting as
they were inside their vehicles clearly
in civilian civilian clothes there was
three bodies that we saw a man
and a number of women inside the white
van that you can see behind me there's a
number out on the road in between the
two lines of vehicles as if they were
trying to escape we know on top of
um
an estimated 25 people who are already
been killed as a result of these Rockets
there's a further 15 people who are
described as critical by the Ukrainian
doctors and who are in theater right now
one of whom is a five-year-old child who
they're trying to perform life-saving
emergency surgery on
now the ukrainians the Red Cross are
here Gathering evidence of Ukrainian
police are gathering evidence the
Ukrainian intelligence of the military
are also Gathering evidence because they
have blamed this quite squarely on the
Russians who they see they are blaming
for trying to intimidate these people
who were going into the
russian-controlled areas to try and get
relatives deliver Aid to those who are
staying behind and try and get relatives
who wanted to flee the area and of
course this is going to be extremely
controversial and be used by the Ukraine
authorities as an another reason why so
many ukrainians are fleeing the area and
don't want to be part of the Russian
territory